and so a lot of folks are celebrating
the arrival of BlackRock why because
BlackRock I mean go look at Jay Powell's
calendar Larry Fink can get time with
Jay Powell could I get time with Jay
Powell no there is a soft corruption and
a very strong incumbency bias that is
not legal by the way and that's part of
the reason why some of the startups who
are challenging here including coinbase
challenging the SEC are challenging the
the old order I think the real game
changer isn't the ETF here would be the
real game changer an ETF that gave the
option to the ETF owner to settle in the
underlying Bitcoin
all right guys bang bang Caitlyn I
thought a great place for us to start
this conversation is the Federal Reserve
and the SEC seem like two of the most
important institutions in the American
Financial system when it comes to
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies you tend to
think that the FED is more important
than the SEC to crypto that may not be
the thought process most people have why
do you think the FED is so much more
important
because it's the single it controls the
single point of failure for the industry
which is U.S dollar access
if we were to have US dollar access
completely choked off which they've
tried to do but haven't succeeded
um then
the digital asset industry would be
completely without US dollar access now
again I don't think it's possible for
them to completely get rid of u.slr
access because for example tether is
somehow getting US dollar access
entirely offshore right we know there's
something called the euro dollar market
which is a market that the US doesn't
control where banks will provide US
dollar balances offshore and out of the
direct reach of the FED but it is
indirectly connected to the FED because
ultimately whoever control whoever
clears dollars for a non-us bank
is ultimately clearing them through a
U.S Bank but those US Dollars can
circulate permanently offshore and never
come back off onshore which is
ultimately what tether is kind of
proving but
um the point is
this US dollar connectivity is a single
point of failure issue for this industry
and and until this industry is a lot
bigger it still does require U.S dollar
access and I've always thought that was
more important uh than than the
Securities piece I understand there are
a lot more people impacted by the
Securities piece but the U.S dollar
access is one of those things where
nobody thinks about it until everybody
thinks about it
talk a little bit as to this US dollar
access uh you mentioned that they've
already tried to cut it off to some
degree there's different levels of maybe
sophistication and abrasiveness they
could take uh I know that there are a
number of lawsuits I think custodia also
has a lawsuit
um uh you know kind of in reference to
the Federal Reserve what are these
lawsuits about and are people trying to
unblock access or kind of what's
Happening Here
well uh the lawsuits are about access to
what's called a master account at the
fed the FED doesn't serve individuals
like you and me the fedslers only banks
and up until a few years ago it was
automatic that a Chartered Bank would
get an account at the FED in fact it was
required by the monetary Control Act of
1980 that the FED that all banks in the
United States keep their reserves on
deposit at the fed that's how the FED
effectuated monetary policy it couldn't
have reserves held outside of the FED in
order to keep monetary policy tightly
controlled by the Board of Governors and
so in 1980 it all got centralized in the
Board of Governors and there's a
requirement for all banks to keep their
reserves there but what has happened in
the last few years is the Fed
reinterpreted quote unquote the law and
started to change how it was granting
access requests and it started with a
Colorado marijuana Credit Union it moved
to the narrow bank which is tnb it's a
bank that was going to service the money
market industry uh and then it it of
course moved to digital assets specialty
Banks uh which is what custodia is and
now there are fintechs as well so you
mentioned there are multiple lawsuits
this is so much bigger than just crypto
it it's it's it goes to the heart of
what is a bank and who who controls
who gets to Define what is a bank and
does the Federal Reserve have a veto
that Congress never gave it over what is
a bank and that's what's being litigated
there are now three lawsuits and I
understand more are coming
so what does it exactly mean when we
talk about a bank that could be in
existence without being beholden to
these kind of federal oversight or
federal regulations
um you know I'm an investor in uh
custodia and it seems like you guys have
started out the state level now trying
to get the master account but there's
still an option for a state level how
does this work
yeah so historically banks have always
been chartered by U.S states ever since
the Inception of the United States
um it's only it was only during the
Civil War that they created a federal
bank chartering Authority called the OCC
and uh but they're equal the states and
the OCC have equal power to Charter
Banks so the punch line is that if a
bank has a State Bank Charter which is
what custodia has historically again it
was always able to plug into the
industry utilities what I mean by that
is the FDIC which is the Insurance Fund
for the industry and the FED which
operates the US dollar payment system
those were historically always viewed as
utilities and Congress always kept
separate the chartering power
so that the states and the OCC chartered
Banks but the utilities didn't have
chartering Authority okay so again
they're trying to blur the lines and
read power for themselves that they did
not have
so you asked about the the how is it
that we've tried to maintain U.S dollar
banking access for digital Assets in the
face of
the the outright hostility from the
Biden Administration and going back
previously the Obama Administration
um which started something called
operation choke point now there's
operation choke point 2.0 uh so Obama
under the Obama Administration was
Operation choke point 1.0 and it's that
started with payday lenders where the
FDIC just did politically didn't like
the payday lenders it was the FDIC and
the Obama justice department decided to
sort of again reinterpret the law
um to repower that they didn't have and
they started to pressure the banks uh
for doing business with high-risk
Industries and It ultimately expanded to
30 different Industries and it's this
laundry list of industries that the left
doesn't like adult entertainment
Firearms ammunition
um oil and gas and of course it started
with the payday lenders the payday
lender sued and originally the FDIC said
oh we never did anything like put
pressure on the bank examiners to
pressure the banks to stop serving these
industries but when the plaintiffs got
access to Discovery guess what it became
clear that the FDIC had lied and so
there was a settlement and the FDIC
agreed to roll it all back but it
unfortunately it came back again
um uh Trump was able to to roll it back
partially but it's now back with with a
Vengeance and uh at the beginning of
operation choke point 2.0 was the
digital asset industry and I will say it
it unfortunately Washington just doesn't
know how to separate the wheat from the
chaff they've basically painted the
entire industry with a broad brush that
we're all you know we're all FTX right
and the reality is FTX was an offshore
exchange never audited never never even
had a board of directors apparently not
regulated and and uh unfortunately
caused a lot of problems for all of us
it should never have been allowed to to
operate and frankly I think if there had
been regulated Alternatives that had
been accepted at the federal level in
Washington DC FTX would not have
operated now we can put the tinfoil hat
on and say well politicians were just
addicted to the money flow in both
political parties and that's why FTX was
allowed to have the impact that it had
um but I I think it's a simpler it's
simpler than that Washington just it has
its head in the sand I saw somebody
refer to it as the Emu approach
um head in the sand thinking that this
whole crypto thing is going to go away a
lot of very smart people think that it's
going to go away and and the world is is
proving them wrong and arguably the door
just opened last week because the FED
announced a novel
activities supervision program if you go
back and look at the fed's denial of
custodia's application back in early
January which was the tip of the sphere
of this whole operation choke point 2.0
and all of government Crackdown on
crypto
the door was slammed shut while seven
months later they've now
opened the Dora crack we don't know what
it means but it's not nothing so when we
look at uh kind of let's take the crypto
entities first we have FTX we have block
file we have Celsius we have Voyager now
we have Prime trust I'm sure there's
others that I'm not even remembering or
kind of including in this group but each
one of them for different reasons uh
there's been bankruptcies customer funds
uh you know at risk Etc what are the
differences between some of these
entities in terms of their legal
structures and how does that then
compare to let's say a federally charted
Bank versus something like what is going
on in Wyoming or somewhere else
well the biggest issue is the biggest
distinction is
is the entity a bank or a non-bank so a
Trust Company a money transmitter those
are non-banks if it's a bank if it's got
a bank Charter there's one very big
distinction that cannot be overcome
which is that Banks cannot be resolved
in Federal Bankruptcy Court they are
exempt from federal bankruptcy Banks and
insurance companies and railroads are
exempt from the federal bankruptcy code
um so what does that mean it means if
the institution fails and it's a bank it
will not end up in chapter 11. if it
fails and it's not a bank like the all
the ones you just listed then it will
probably end up in chapter 11. we just
saw that this week with prime trust they
started in state what's called State
receivership or the state ordered them
not to operate there there's Nevada
chartered Trust Company and uh the state
ordered them to shut down but now
um six weeks later they just went into
Federal Bankruptcy Court what's the
biggest impact of that in a federal
bankruptcy the the
design to maximize the value of the
estate's assets
for the stakeholders they don't the law
does not say that customers have to be
put first in a state receivership by
contrast
customers are typically put first
usually by law so there's a big
difference if your financial institution
goes bust if it's a bank it's you're
more much more likely to be protected as
a customer than if you're dealing with a
non-bank that could end up in chapter
11. now what's the impact of that we saw
that in Celsius there's a lot of
misunderstanding out there people think
that just because the assets are held in
trust that means that they're immune to
taking a haircut in bankruptcy well
Celsius is exhibit a for where that's
not true because the judge in that case
held that the custody assets at Celsius
were indeed the property of the
customers but the judge would not let
them take their assets out of Celsius
because of the possibility that there
were so-called preferences and until all
those preferences cleared the custody
customers couldn't get their assets out
so even though they were deemed to own
the assets guess what they voluntarily
agreed to take a 27 and a half percent
haircut so they got 72 and a half cents
on the dollar voluntarily so that they
didn't get stuck in years of litigation
this is what's called strong Army and
that's what happens in chapter 11 you
can get strong-armed into agreeing to
take a haircut because until all those
preferences are cleared you're not going
to get your money and so even though
they were deemed to own the assets that
cost benefit analysis done by that
Committee of custody customers ended up
concluding that they were better off
taking a 27.5 cent haircut on every
dollar so just so they could get the
money out now and then they were all
those preferences they gave up all their
preferences they were they they got a
release from the bankruptcy court that
no one could come after them for
preferences again so they they're now
taking their money free and clear but
only 72 and a half cents that's the
difference so yes it does matter that
there are banks here now Bank of New
York Mellon has been in in custody
although as you know they've been
essentially handcuffed so not been able
to
um to grow because of the
um the sec's accounting pronouncements
that are that are keeping publicly
traded Banks from
um from from building big custody
businesses but custodia is exempt from
that because we're not a publicly traded
company
so when you look at Prime trust which
one are they going to fall into do you
are they going to end up following more
probably the Celsius path or do they end
up being able to protect customer assets
or we don't know yet
we don't know that's the point nobody
can say with certainty so all these
folks who are out there saying oh that's
those those assets are those or their
assets
yes but
they might be stuck in a preference
fight
um and and you know it does matter I I
one of the things that I think is so so
so important for our industry is that
everybody has to take some
responsibility to start doing
counterparty credit risk analysis on the
on the counterparties and the reason
that I'm saying this and to answer your
question is that Prime trust was engaged
in a whole bunch of activities that
muddied the waters okay I pointed out in
their customer agreement that they were
trading with customer assets this was
lawful in the cash accounts and so
basically those cash accounts belong to
the estate they don't belong to the
customers so any of the cash accounts
are already not going to be deemed to be
the customer's assets but even if it
even if the customers trust assets are
deemed to be long to the customers Prime
trust was engaging in some of the
lending businesses what does that mean
if your counterpart is engaging in those
lending businesses they're creating
preferences that may get fought over if
the customer if the counterparty ends up
going bust okay and we we're seeing that
in the block file and Celsius
um chapter 11s so you want to be with if
you're going to use a counterparty and I
think you and I both are are big not
your keys not your coins folks
encouraging people to learn how to
self-custody your assets but there are
certain entities out there that legally
cannot
um a registered investment advisor or a
money a mutual fund manager that by law
they have to segregate the management of
the assets from the custody of the
assets okay so they're not legally
allowed to self-custody so now what okay
what they want to do is do the
counterparty credit risk analysis of
understanding who their custodian is if
their custodian is engaging in lending
activities yeah that that means if that
custodian fails probably there there's
going to be a fight over preferences in
chapter 11. if that custodian is trying
to be all things to all people and and
engaging in Risky crypto protocols that
are not as tested as say Bitcoin is you
might just have Bitcoin there and think
well I'll be fine but no if that
custodian goes down and it's not a bank
you're going to be in the in the mix
just like with Celsius so Prime trust
the fact that it's going chapter 11 just
like Celsius did unfortunately means I
think there are going to be some adverse
surprises for folks but we don't know
that's the point there's so much
uncertainty that comes with any chapter
11 process nobody can say definitively
that even the trust customers will get a
hundred cents on the dollar back uh we
just don't know and only time will tell
so what you all are doing I think most
people here bank and they start thinking
US dollars they start thinking all about
kind of the Legacy Financial system but
obviously Bitcoin and stable coins is a
huge part of your plan
um what exactly is custodia trying to do
around like Bitcoin custody or things
with the state of coin
um whether you get the federal Charter
or not talk a little bit about kind of
how you can you can uh kind of mesh
these two worlds together yeah well it's
not easy to do that but yes we are
measuring US dollars in Bitcoin custody
we're on the verge of launching Bitcoin
custody and as we've publicly announced
our US dollar deposit business is
launched as is US dollar money market
funds uh both our live and operating and
uh and and yeah pretty exciting
um so why put those two things together
because you need to be able to safely
Bridge the two uh and I I feel very
strongly that that the new system the
so-called web3 system should not hurt
the tradition Regional Financial system
and the traditional Financial system
should not hurt crypto or web3 or
Bitcoin whatever reference you want to
call it it is a new and different
Financial system these are new and
different payment rails and they don't
mess well with traditional Finance why
let me give you a quick example Bitcoin
settles every 10 minutes on average
there's a new block appended to the
Bitcoin blockchain every 10 minutes
it takes you at least a day to settle an
ACH payment for US Dollars okay so now
you're looking at 10 minutes versus one
day even if you send a Fed wire it's not
programmable you're not going to be able
to ensure that your US Dollars reaches
their reaches the destination at say 10
30 p.m on a Saturday night but if but
you can program a stable coin for US
dollars to reach the destination at 10
30 pm on a state on a Saturday night
um so so long story short what we're
trying to do is create real-time growth
settlement where we match the settlement
of U.S dollars with Bitcoin and in order
to do that it has to be done under under
the same roof now we're also offering
the custody Services as a bank we just
talked about why it's so important to
have a clean counterparty and a
counterparty that that is a bank if
you're a fiduciary that's what you want
why is it that all the Securities
custodians Are banks it's exactly what I
just talked about in those earlier
questions
um because because Banks treat customers
a lot better in bankruptcy than
non-banks do so long story short
um that's what custodia is doing we're
we're building the fiduciary asset
manager of choice fiduciary sorry
fiduciary custodian of choice
um for Bitcoin because we're offering
what is the best customer protections
and the most customer friendly legal and
Regulatory regime but we're also doing
it connected directly to US Dollars now
one of things that becomes interesting
is we've got BlackRock coming in we've
got Fidelity obviously he's been here
for a while a number of these really
large organizations all starting to put
together ETF applications become more
interested there's others who I don't
know if their plans are public or not so
I don't want to mention by name but very
very large financial institutions that
are sinking hundreds of employees of
resources literally hundreds of millions
of dollars to build out things for this
space whether it's infrastructure else
how does that change the pressure on
either the Federal Reserve the OCC or
kind of like the bank world right it's
one thing if you're like oh the the
crypto people are the crazy people on
the internet and you know uh we don't
like them it's another thing when Larry
Fink is on National Television being
like we believe this is an asset class
that's going to be Global in nature and
we want to be a leader and we have you
know a trillion plus dollars and like
we're coming those two things seem very
different in the eyes of regulators is
it changing the conversation for what
you're trying to do
uh not in banking no um but I will say
you're hitting on something really
important which is the soft Corruption
of the system there is it there is an
anti-startup bias there is a very strong
pro-incumbency bias right and so a lot
of folks are celebrating the arrival of
BlackRock why because BlackRock I mean
go look at Jay Powell's calendar
Larry Fink can get time with Jay Powell
could I get time with Jay Powell no I
asked for it never got it okay so um
there is a soft corruption and a very
strong incumbency bias that is not legal
by the way and that's part of the reason
why some of the startups who are
challenging here including coinbase
challenging the SEC
um are challenging the the old order
it's not legal that it's done this way
um now I don't know that blackrock's
going to have an advantage or not
because there's such a strong
anti-bitcoin bias at the SEC right now
but let me tell you what I think would
be very very very interesting is that if
a spot ETF is approved typically ETFs
allow redemption in cash and redemption
in the underlying but it's typically the
issuer that has the option to decide
whether to redeem for the underlying it
doesn't that's not the right of the ETF
holder I think the real game changer
isn't the ETF the real which I've said
publicly is a double-edged sword because
of all the you know rehab application
games that that ETF Market managers can
play here's the here would be the real
game changer an ETF that gave the option
to the ETF owner to settle in the
underlying Bitcoin
take that option away from the ETF
issuer and give it to the owner or give
it to both of them right now the ETF
becomes the wrapper through which if
that happens the market uh that would
allow that would allow customers to buy
Bitcoin through the ETS structure but
keep the discipline on the ETF manager
that at all times they damn well better
keep enough Bitcoin in that custody pool
to redeem one for one at all times and
they cannot play rehypothecation games
where they're issuing more claims to
Bitcoin in other words more ETF units in
this case than they have real Bitcoin in
custody if there were a real ability for
the owner to redeem for actual Bitcoin
that would be the game changer and so I
think that I would love to see that and
frankly would love for custodia to be
part of that to be clear we're not
approved for Bitcoin custody yet we're
waiting for final regulatory approval
but uh knock on wood we will be soon
when you look out at um kind of the
regulatory environment in the United
States are there other places around the
world that are one Company's trying to
get kind of this meshing of crypto and
in the banking system and then two what
are the responses from Regulators in
those uh jurisdictions or those regions
are they running into similar problems
or are those regulatory bodies letting
them get banking license and stuff like
that what's going on kind of
internationally yeah it's the opposite
of what if what is happening in the U.S
which is why the U.S is just those of us
who are part of the industry who are
actually trying to do lawful business
and work with The Regulators are
dismayed at the terrible policy decision
and again I think they it only took them
seven months to start to open the door
uh to realize that this isn't going to
go away and the FED in their new novels
activity supervision program acknowledge
they don't have the skill set and that
they're going to be working with the
banking industry that the technology
industry fintechs and academics is what
they listed in their public press
release last week so that's an
acknowledgment that's a that's a that's
a big acknowledgment that they don't
have the skill set in-house and that
they need to go get it so that they
understand how how to administer these
novel activities and to be fair the
novel activities went beyond just crypto
but of course it um they they did
mention crypto so coming back to answer
your question
um Singapore just approved a stable coin
issuing
a regulatory regime just this week
um we've seen a Swiss Regulators not
just allowing Swiss banks to custody
crypto but to hold crypto on their
balance sheets
um we've seen the bank for international
settlements which sets the the um the
bis Capital requirements for Basel III
what's called Basel III for Global Banks
um proposed to allow Banks to hold
crypto on balance sheet which the FED in
the custodia case said hell no not ever
um right so the US is really an outlier
among the the more developed Nations uh
and of course I I would be remiss if I
weren't mentioning what's going on in
Hong Kong there's a real opening of of
the Chinese market to the crypto
industry again after a big Crackdown
China has gone back and forth between
cracking down and opening up cracking
down and opening up and I think in part
in reaction to the US
what the US has done China has
substantially reopened and is actually
putting pressure on the banks to give
bank accounts to the crypto industry so
the US is just a massive outlier here my
last question for you is
um you mentioned that you try to get
time with Jay Powell at the Federal
Reserve and you never got that time is
that a common request for people to make
of Jay uh is it common for them to deny
that you mentioned you know large
Financial organizations get meetings all
the time what was kind of your reaction
why do you think that you were denied
the time with a j-pal uh it's a good
question I don't know we we were an
applicant uh so but we repeatedly asked
for time I do know that others in the
industry have gotten times with fed
Governors I never met never met any of
the people who made the decision
ultimately likely in in the custodial
membership application
um which was done by the the Federal
Reserve board except for I was on a
panel with Lyle Brainerd back in 2016
and then again in 2018 and that's uh
that's when I I met her but otherwise
the people who voted on the custodia
membership application never never got
access to them again that's part of the
part of the interesting uh uh uh Dynamic
that occurred there but guess who got an
hour with Jay Powell take a wild guess
who got an hour with Jay Powell
uh three letter initials
yep Sam magman free got an hour with Jay
pal yep what do you think they talked
about yep
I don't know you know it was before of
course the whole thing blew up uh and
and it was revealed to be a fraud
um but uh I don't know I mean at that
point what he was after was basically
you know controlling the regulatory
structure right part of his pack and his
spreading money around to pro-crypto
politicians on both sides of the aisle
admittedly more so to Democrats but a
lot to Republicans as well
um and by the way go look at who gets to
meet with Jay Powell how many people
actually get one hour meetings with Jay
Powell this wasn't just any meeting
Larry Finkel get 15 minutes but Sam
bakeman free got an hour with Jay Paul
that's public knowledge I don't know why
the Press hasn't picked that up but um I
don't know what they talked about it
would be interesting if anyone from the
Press is out there listening uh it is
public information that Sam begman freed
spent an hour with Jay Paul what did
they talk about yeah that is pretty fast
but I will say one thing is that
happened right before Alameda took a
control stake in Moonstone Bank
Moonstone was the bank that that
um I think there were a couple of media
Outlets that New York Times I think in
produce who broke the story that Alameda
did this back door what's called a
charter strip acquisition took it bought
a tiny bank and and with the intention
of changing its business plan to be Crow
Pro crypto uh they were shortcutting the
process and the FED didn't figure it out
uh one of custodia's advisors wrote an
op-ed in American Banker saying that
acquisition violated the fed's control
rules and the FED should have caught it
um but I happen to know there are five
of those in process right now we'll see
if the if the federal Regulators catch
them it's very ironic because those of
us who are going through the front door
asking for permission
um are getting slapped down but those
going through the back door uh trying to
pull a fast one
um have gotten through and moonstone is
one of those and so one of the questions
I don't recall the precise timing but I
think the Moonstone Alameda took over
Moonstone Bank in like February
um and the the FTX meeting with Jay
Powell happened right before that I
think in January those I might have
those dates off by a little bit but not
by much the time the timing that
separated Alameda taking over Moonstone
Bank
um um was not very long after FTX the
FTX meeting as I recall
so we have a question here from Luke
Luke if you want to come off uh mute and
ask it
yeah hey my question is I don't know if
you can talk any more about I hate to
bring sdx up again but for the average
person now it's so confusing where it's
at what's kind of like the next stage is
just for the average person in terms of
recovery making so I'll take a first
stab at it and but pump you may know you
may know more I I looked at the docket
for that bankruptcy filing and it is
staggering and it's not shocking that
it's staggering because if you looked at
the corporate structure there were
hundreds of legal entities in that
corporate structure and unwinding all
that just just finding all of those
legal entities is is a lot of work it
sounds like from what has been disclosed
FTX did not maintain accurate books and
Records so there has to be a lot of
forensic accounting that's that's being
done and the amount of of consultant
fees including legal and accounting fees
in that bankruptcy is staggering
precisely because of how complex it is
it's going going and finding all those
assets but yes you're right that from
what I have read they have found a lot
of assets and they're also clawing back
lot of assets as I understand it every
politician who received donations has
been asked to give the donations back by
the justice department so
um that's uh that's that's significant
they are getting assets I don't know
what the ultimate settlement is going to
be and again it's super complex because
it's an offshore bankruptcy it's not all
onshore in the United States uh at the
time when that happened and it all came
out I said this is probably going to be
the most complex bankruptcy in U.S
history and based on what I can see
right now just the number of dot of
documents in the in the docket and the
number of lawsuits involved it's uh it
is shaping up to be that way pom do you
have anything to add I don't have much
to add I I think the two things
um that I'm paying attention to one are
all the clawback stuff so we've seen uh
them already go back to a number of
different uh Venture funds they had
invested in you know different
organizations obviously the politicians
you mentioned like there's a whole bunch
of stuff uh where they're trying to
track down hey where did this money go
uh and like how do we get some of it
back
um and then the second thing uh is the
restarting of FTX like I actually think
that that's like a pretty interesting
component of this where
um I don't know if you ever build it
back to what it was but if you can even
build it to a fraction of that from a
liquidity standpoint a revenue
standpoint you know could you actually
uh you know somehow get more funds back
for these FCX creditors probably now is
that you know one cent on the dollar or
is that 50 cents on the dollar it's not
unclear
um but I think a lot of folks are
focused on like how much money can we
recover from the existing assets and a
very big variable here is like how much
money can be derived from future
earnings or Equity value by restarting
the exchange and kind of coming out the
other side I don't know what that answer
is but it'll be pretty fascinating to
watch that occur
yeah I mean as you know pomped that that
that platform was one of the most
favored platforms because of the tech
unfortunately what we know is that
behind it there was roughshod operations
uh if any you know it doesn't sound like
they were even were keeping books and
Records it certainly wasn't in a
position ever to be audited right so
um but the tech is is was by far the the
favorite attack of users in the industry
um and you know what I guess the message
I would have is as someone who did lose
money in Mount gox it was the same kind
of thing I was like well that was the
only way to get Bitcoin way back then
and so I lost money in Mount Cox I
hadn't taught myself how to how to do
private key custody to self-custody the
assets uh and nine years later I still
haven't gotten the money back
um I don't know if I ever will actually
but long story short um you got to be
careful because just because something
is the only or the best doesn't mean
that's the counterparty you want to face
Caitlin one last question that I have
for you you is when you look at the
United States and obviously we now are
getting a growing number of politicians
uh at the local state and even Federal
level who are sympathetic to this
technology this industry these assets
and I think to maybe the plight of the
entrepreneur trying to deal with the
regulatory uncertainty Etc
um yeah how do you see crypto Bitcoin
stable coins Etc playing out with the
presidential election so it's like you
know all of these politicians we've
already seen that playing out but this
feels like maybe it's the first
presidential election where Bitcoin is a
part of the conversation it's definitely
not the thing but it's a thing and we've
seen multiple presidential candidates
come out in support of Bitcoin does that
become the norm or what are you thinking
there I love it I mean it is it is
somewhat generational it but the the the
leaders in both political parties
polling right now are both of a
different generation than the average
Bitcoin or let's put it that way
um and they're both anti-crypto right
Trump himself was very anti-crypto
because Steve mnuchin his treasury
secretary was anti-cryptal although it
has just been disclosed that he owns
some ethereum and then we know what
Biden the Biden administration's view is
it's it's virulently anti-crypto and you
know especially going after the people
who are trying hardest to work with The
Regulators it's been designed to sort of
you know shoot the scallion the stallion
to scatter the herd so to speak and I
don't think the Biden Administration is
going to change although I will say
um there are some people in the Bible
Administration who were who are very
pro-crypto it's it it's it's a strange
bedfellows kind of thing where it
doesn't cut across traditional political
parties and it doesn't
um cut across even you know within both
the Trump Administration where you had
Brian Brian Brooks who was very Pro
um and Steve mnuchin who was very
against there are very Pro folks within
the Biden white house but the people in
charge of Economic Policy right now are
not among them so um so long story short
yes I think it will become a
presidential
um election issue but right now it's the
secondary candidates who are talking
about it there's pretty much unanimity
among those secondary candidates
um who have spoken about it that they're
Pro I suspect uh the neocon types are
against we haven't heard
um
um Tim Scott yet come out and say what
he thinks he is the ranking member of
the Senate Banking Committee so any any
legislation any crypto legislation that
goes through before the end of the Biden
Administration must go through him so I
think it's ultimately going to
um he's going to have to take a position
at some point and
um my gut is that he's going to be
positive because of the the freedom
arguments but boy there are a couple
candidates in most political parties who
are making beautiful
Arguments for the freedom to transact
financially and for be able to protect
Financial privacy I'm I'm spending time
with multiple of that of them their
campaign staffs I'm not endorsing
anybody but I'm willing on a policy
discussion matter to talk to anybody
who's interested in learning about
Bitcoin and coming out with policies and
I just this morning someone asked me how
do we how do we maintain Financial
privacy and balance the policy goal of
not allowing the financial system to be
used for money laundering and the answer
is you fix the third party Doctrine
which is the doctrine that once you give
up any data to a third party you've
given up a privacy interest in it and
the government can go to the bank or to
your cell phone company and get every
financial transaction you've ever done
uh and get every every cell phone
location ping that your cell phone has
ever paid right that data is
commercially available go and especially
the banks just have to turn it over when
the government comes calling
um and so the easiest way to deal with
that is to say all right
um for money laundering laundering
purposes the government can use that
data but the government can't use that
data for anything else so just pass a
law that says it cannot be used as
evidence in in criminal cases in civil
cases that it is private for everything
except for money laundering that that
that would boy that would solve a lot of
problems that would that would help help
keep privacy so if you see a
presidential candidate start espousing
that
um uh you might might uh might trace it
back to it to me because they thought it
was a pretty good idea so we'll see if
it if it actually comes out in policy
but that's how you start to restore
privacy rights and Fourth Amendment
protections that have been completely
gutted by the fact that the government
doesn't need to go to a court and prove
probable cause to get a search warrant
they'll just go buy your data from a
third party data provider and use it as
evidence against you and until we
restore the Fourth Amendment protections
unfortunately uh you know the the walls
are closing in on Americans privacy on
our fine on our rights and freedoms to
transact and I hope that uh that a
politician breaks through and uh one one
specifically that is truly committed to
Freedom
so I'll leave you with one last thing
which is a complete hypothesis on my
standpoint or from my perspective I
think that Trump's uh disclosure of
ethereum
um it's unclear whether it's ethereum or
it's Assets in an ethereum based wallet
and regardless of that distinction I
think is probably related to the nfts
that he was selling as a fundraiser
so he was doing all like these like
Trump nfts which like look ridiculous
and you know are exactly what kind of
you would expect
um but my guess is that either it was
ethereum he was receiving right in
exchange for those nfts or he has like
nfts left over or like maybe he like
puts some aside or whatever which is
funny because it's very different than I
think people who are celebrating like oh
Trump's into like crypto now right like
no actually he just saw it as like a
vehicle if that is what it is to make
money yeah to fundraise right
um and like regardless what you think of
him as a president or an individual or
whatever yeah it almost speaks to the
fact of like this is a growing part of
the world where somebody can do that
they can say it's not just an investment
type vehicle it is a Commerce type thing
and so right you know eventually you're
going to get businesses that do this
you're gonna get people who are running
who you don't know are they buying these
assets for investment purposes was it
for something else that they did it's
just going to become much more you know
kind of normal in the world than maybe
what it was you know five years ago
well don't forget Melania issued nfts as
well right and since they're married
they they could be hers could be related
to her issuing issuing them as well uh
but you're absolutely right your broader
point is absolutely right this is all
normalized now I saw I think it was a
coinbase survey 19 of New Yorkers own
digital assets that's all New Yorkers
that's not you know within a certain
Generation
Um it's obviously going to be a lot
higher in the younger generations and a
lot lower in the older Generations but
19 of every New Yorker owns crypto
that's pretty meaningful
um and I think the next bull market
maybe we can end on a on a on an up note
the next bull market uh which is likely
to be ushered in after the happening of
Bitcoin in April of 2024
typically what happens is the miners
consolidate and uh because a lot of the
the old mining that was Reliant upon the
higher block rewards that get cut in
half at every happening that those old
minors will be shut down you see a uh
you see some of those companies go out
of business you see the the hash rate
come offline and then after that
consolidation period which typically
lasts about six months the bull market
gets ushered in okay what I just
described to you is a fundamental
process this is not a technical thing
um but a lot of people will trade ahead
of it and what we saw there was a big
debate four years ago well three and a
half years ago over
um whether the happening was priced in
and it was not
um and this whole question of of like
efficient markets hypothesis we all know
the happenings coming so
um it has to be priced in right and it
was not priced in because these are very
fundamental things and nobody that you
know the miners will keep Mining and
until the very last minute that that
they're that their machines are no
longer profitable and then they will add
they will all shut them off they're not
trading ahead of that
um maybe arguably because there's a
better there are deeper Futures markets
than there used to be some of them are
hedging so that they can trade ahead of
it but I still think this is going to be
a pretty fundamental phenomenon and we
are likely to have a bull market it's
not going to be as material each time
the bull markets are less in their
amplitude
um but they're still coming and the
impact of that on adoption when all
these
anti-crypto Army folks uh who are trying
to kill it and are trying to argue that
it's worth zero and it's going to go to
its intrinsic value which they say is
zero and when it's when they're proven
wrong
all of a sudden I think you're gonna see
doors opening right and like the FED
announced last week with its novel
activities supervision program It
reversed itself seven months later after
saying essentially hell no now it's well
we've got to figure out how to supervise
this stuff because it is causing risks
in the banking system and candidly
that's a positive development and I
think um we're the US is ultimately
going to pull its head out of the sand
and get there uh but the rest of the
world and the markets themselves are
gonna just keep right on going
regardless of what the US does
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or find out more about
custodia
go to bank.com and uh pretty
Twitter and Linkedin
ster
Caitlin thank you so much for doing this
I always enjoyed talking to you I always
learned something and we would
definitely do it again in the future
likewise yeah thanks and thanks for for
uh being a guinea pig I was one of your
first guinea pigs on your original
podcast you were okay I love helping you
out trying to to try this new format so
thanks everybody for joining